Google has an amazing
cloud infrastructure
for running your business,
mobile apps, data analytics.
But did you know Google is also
a great place to do science?
I'd like to tell you about how
Google is helping bring data
science and life
science together
to benefit health
and basic research.
First, some background.
The human genome contains around
6 billion nucleotide letters--
the A's, C's, G's and T's.
That's 3 billion
from each parent.
In theory that's not a
huge amount of information,
especially if you compress it.
People's DNA is 99.9% identical,
but in practice the files
start out much
bigger because you
need to do a lot of analysis
to identify that 0.1% that
makes each of us unique.
When the scientific
community sequenced
the first human genome
it took 15 years and cost
around $3 billion.
Thankfully, since
then the time and cost
has plummeted dramatically.
As you'd expect with an
exponential price drop
like that the volume of
sequencing has exploded.
Projects are already underway
to sequence millions of genomes.
How much data is that?
Let's think about it.
At 100 gigabytes
per genome, if you
wanted to read the DNA
of everyone in Moscow
it would take more than 1.2
million terabyte hard drives.
So this is a really
big challenge.
Well, Google knows a thing
or two about big data.
The Google search index
is around 100 petabytes,
yet search results come back
in a quarter of a second.
There's a huge opportunity to
bring data science and life
science together.
Imagine the impact if
researchers everywhere
had powerful tools to
distinguish between people
who become sick and
those who remain healthy,
between patients who
respond to treatment
and those whose
condition worsens,
between pathogens
that cause outbreaks
and those that are harmless.
Imagine getting results
in seconds instead of days
without owning a data center.
That's the world we're
trying to bring about.
Our first public
announcement was
that we joined the Global
Alliance for Genomics
and Health, an
international consortium
of over 180 top universities,
research hospitals,
medical centers, health care
providers, public health
organizations,
and companies that
are committed to the same goal.
We're a computer
science company,
so we're contributing
to the teams that
are defining a standard API
to promote interoperability,
like the W3C for genomics.
We are hosting
public data that's
available through the API and
we're building open source
software showing how to work
with big genomic data using
that API.
To give just one example
of interoperability,
here is a sample
genome browser that
can connect the
API to access data.
In the US the National Center
for Biotechnology Information
implemented the API for
their sequence read archive.
And the European
Bioinformatics Institute
also implemented the API.
At Google we have a
third implementation.
Even though all
three groups store
DNA sequences using
different internal formats,
the same software can
connect to all of them
without code
changes-- and this has
happened in a matter of weeks.
The progress is fantastic.
The Global Alliance
has a GitHub project
where you can read the
discussion about the data model
and check out the
draft API spec.
We have additional examples in
our Genomics team repository
showing how to call the
API from Python, Java, R,
as well as how to analyze
genomic information in two
modes-- by doing
interactive queries
and massively
parallel processing.
Check out the open source repo
on GitHub by clicking here.
And of course, you can learn
more about Google Genomics
by checking out our
online developer docs.
Exploring genomic data
can be a challenge--
partly because the
files are so large
and partly because many of
the computing technologies
to work with them were
built decades ago.
Let's look at some of the 21st
century computing technologies
that we can use to
explore DNA sequences.
One tool that Google has for
exploratory data analysis
is called BigQuery.
The underlying
technology was built
to process trillions of lines of
log files at interactive speed.
In our first prototype
using Google technology
to look at genetic
variation we discovered
that BigQuery is a good match
for scientific questions
around population
genetics, including things
like minor allele frequency,
transition/transversion
ratios, and more.
The way it works
is really simple.
Type SQL query
into your browser,
hit Enter, wait a few
seconds, get results
on gigantic data sets.
There's also an API so
that you can call it
from scripts or programs.
Here's an example of
what a query looks like.
It looks like SQL.
We have multiple
examples in GitHub
and you can copy and
paste, or modify,
to ask real biological questions
and get answers in seconds.
Now, let's look at
what you can do.
We loaded up the
1,000 Genomes data
and did some quick
summary statistics.
What did we find?
By design of the study about
half of the participants
are female, half male.
Multiple geographic
groups are represented
and some families
were sequenced,
but mostly individuals.
In the year 2000 researchers
applied an earlier
genetic testing technology
on 255 individuals.
They found evidence that
Africans are more genetically
diverse than other
populations in the world,
and they're the likely
origin of modern humans.
In 2009 large scale sequencing
confirmed the findings.
Today, you can
test these findings
on over 1,000 Genomes using
BigQuery in just a few seconds.
The key finding, Africans--
shown in light red--
have more genetic variation.
Hopefully this gives
just a little bit
of a flavor for the
kinds of questions
you can ask interactively with
BigQuery-- by typing a query,
having a sip of coffee,
looking at the answer,
and typing a slightly
different query.
Another way to explore genomic
data is using MapReduce,
the same distributed
computing paradigm
Google uses to generate
the search index.
MapReduce is a way to
process data in parallel
by putting lots
of servers on it.
We decided to run a MapReduce
in 1,000 Genomes data.
Each circle represents
an individual's variance.
Using MapReduce we ran a
principal component analysis,
or PCA, to project the data
into two dimensions that
explain the variation.
It took about a page of code
and ran in around 15 minutes.
In this plot we see three
clear clusters form,
but what do they mean?
Color coding the
plots by population,
we see that the three
clusters correspond
to the super populations of the
world-- Africans in light red,
Europeans in blue,
and Asians in green.
And see this point in pink
in-between Europe and Africa?
Those are African-Americans
from the American Southwest.
This is very cool, but what
are the x- and y-axes mean?
Let's look a little
closer with BigQuery.
This bit of SQL selects
how many variants
occur in a single allele
versus in two alleles-- that
means in one copy versus both
copies of each chromosome.
Copy, paste, hit Enter.
A few seconds later
you've got an answer.
Plotting the results with
R we see that we just
generated a very similar plot
to the principal component
analysis.
With MapReduce and
BigQuery we have
two ways of working
with data and we
can go back and
forth between them.
Now, just imagine what we
can do with 1,000 times
as many samples.
With a million genomes
representing a wide range
of phenotypes,
diseases, treatments,
environments-- think
of what you might
learn about the genetic
basis of disease,
drug response, and more.
And for that to
happen the world is
going to need a
lot of computers.
Hopefully these
examples give you
a taste of what's possible by
bringing data science and life
science together on
Google Cloud Platform.
All of this is
available to you today.
To get started yourself you
could read the developer docs,
look at the code samples,
try the genome browser,
and join our discussion forum.
I'm Jonathan Bingham.
Thanks for listening.